an absolute bombshell report from the
New York Times yesterday by the way New
York Times in washington post's sort of
in a contest of doing real journalism
all of a sudden I think we can all
appreciate that the New York Times
reported yesterday the Donald Trump in
that infamous February meeting with now
fired FBI director James Comey asked
James Comey to end the FBI's
investigation into disgraced national
security adviser Michael Flynn and the
Russia scandal we've learned about this
because of a memo that James Comey wrote
after the meeting Donald Trump
reportedly said quote I hope you can see
your way clear to letting this go to
letting Flynn go he's a good guy I hope
you can let this go to which James Comey
reportedly responded with only I agree
he is a good guy opting not to talk
about ending the investigation at Donald
Trump's request this is the president
expressing a total disregard for the
Independence of the Justice Department
this is what dictators do this is at
face value obstruction of justice when
you look around the world at
dictatorships and repressive regimes and
anti-democratic States there is no
independent press there is no judicial
independence there's no independence of
the Justice Department the equivalent of
the Justice Department in those
countries this is the president saying
don't do that investigation what is the
president know about when an
investigation should start or end that
is for the FBI to determine this is
taking a stand against separation of
powers and even jason Chaffetz Pat
Republican who seems hesitant to
investigate anything that involves a
Republican had to concede that yes this
might be a concern
raising a saying quote this rate would
raise questions as to whether the
president attempted to influence or
impede impede being the key word the FBI
we're reaching is there a redline we
haven't yet crossed here well I think
there's still reason to be skeptical
because there wasn't a third person in
that room it was just Trump and Comey
Sarah know it's kind of like you have to
choose the word between one or the other
the problem is
you know Trump specifically his
credibility has been questioned so much
at this point yet where is Comey his
credibility isn't so much questioned and
the veracity of his claims were never
questioned in fact maybe his judgment a
little bit too much much of what James
Comey has said has ultimately been
confirmed to be true and again this is
the meeting as pat says this was a
meeting between Donald Trump and James
Comey it took place the day after
Michael Flynn resigned and this is
clearly if true all part of Trump trying
to just cover up the Russia stuff tell
Flynn to resign tell Comey to stop
investigating it'll all go away
obviously the White House has denied
James Comey z' version of events in that
memo we are now of trying to figure out
whether that memo will be subpoenaed and
the White House is sort of trying to
frame Comey as seeking revenge because
Trump fired him I went on Drudge Report
yesterday and they had some headline
like Comey starts revenge or something
along those lines
again the memo was written months ago
unless you believe that the memo has
since been fabricated the memo was
written months ago and I guess you'd
have to believe anticipating eventually
being fired back in February James Comey
wrote a fake memo that he could later
talk about or something like that I mean
again you it starts to become very
complex to go down that path it's very
hard to explain and also are we just to
believe that Trump is so concerned with
the well-being of Michael Flynn I mean
he's they've only known each other for a
year or two you'd have to think that if
there is a smoking gun when it comes to
this Russia investigation yeah via
Michael Flynn and he's kind of showing
his hand here and as far as the notes
specifically and the credibility aspect
that Pat was talking about it's
important to know that in court an FBI
agents notes are basically held as
credible evidence of conversations
there's no assumption that the case
notes made by an FBI agent are of sort
of questionable accuracy when you're
talking about these in the context of a
court proceeding and that's really
important to know when we just say well
hey listen it's one person's word
against another person's word what is in
the memo generally speaking would be
considered credible evidence in a court
situation and that actually is important
to know interesting yeah and if there
was going to be a third person
the room it would have been Jeff
Sessions the Attorney General who is
actually James commis boss but I think
Trump wanted to make sure that it was
just them two in the room and you can
see why interestingly Jeff Sessions said
he would be refusing himself from
everything related to Trump Russia of
course he was the guy that initially we
found out recommended the firing of
James Comey who was the guy leading the
investigation into Russia not exactly
the type of recusal that you would
imagine would be taking place as well he
is the top lawyer in the country who
also perjured himself yes he did Trump
thinks that this is sort of like a
business situation right he's working a
deal hey let me get Jimmy in here and
I'm going to tell him to just cut the
investigation out blah blah blah we're
talking about a criminal investigation
here by the FBI at the highest level and
Donald Trump apparently saw no problem
with and had no shame about trying to
meddle with that we are quickly moving
in the direction of crossing some more
red lines I don't know what red lines
remain like I guess maybe Trump
personally killing someone right I mean
you said I could kill someone on Fifth
Avenue nothing nothing would happen
we're quickly getting to that being the
only red line that hasn't yet been
crossed if it would even be one yeah
you'd have to imagine there's some
plausible deniability but if these
things just keep adding up it gets to a
point where you're getting
conspiratorial to deny them yeah it's
that you would have to believe a
far-reaching conspiracy to believe that
there's nothing to see here I think
that's a really good point